[Music]
did you want to tell your lean story oh
[__] yeah yeah yeah I'll tell it okay um
I don't know where I left off in it but
long story short I loved drugs in high
school I was a drug addict it was fun it
was lit I got it over though when I was
younger don't do that as I do um but in
like high school I like
um really wanted to try lean cuz it was
like preand demic but like at the end of
like every rapper talking about just
imagine you guys think of like you know
like when you open the social studies
book and it's like the Paleolithic Era
like you have like this time map in your
head like it's pandemic it's pandemic
post lemic yeah um so all the rappers
were talking about it and I was like big
into like sound SoundCloud rap like I
loved SoundCloud um and so like everyone
was talking about that [__] so I was
like ooh I want to try it and so I hit
up like one of my homies um who like was
my small ass Town drug dealer and I was
like yo can I get like lean he was like
yeah like I got activ activist which
like is like goated Lean Like The
activist um goated
lean it doesn't exist anymore it's like
impossible to get you seen all those
tweets of like all the dudes like
getting like old like oh like the the
bottles of yeah like they're like
talking about like wine yeah like yeah
un Uncorked activist yeah yeah yeah
sealed bottles of activist um but yeah I
like really wanted to try it and he was
like yeah I have activist and I was like
damn like this is lit and at the time I
worked at a gas station so I like was at
work and he was like I can get give it
to you now and I cuz I didn't want to
like drive to pick it up cuz I was like
weird about [__] like that so I was just
like drop it off on my car in my car so
I like unlocked my car for a drug dealer
and like was like just put it in like
the middle console like it'll be fine um
and so he put it in there thankfully he
didn't steal my car I wish it did
because or I wish he did because I would
have like a sick ass story to tell but
like um I like went home and I called my
friend I was like I got lean I got lean
and we like made our little dirty
Sprites I like bought Jolly Ranchers and
Sprite and got foam cups from like the
gas station I worked at and I like went
home and I was like we have it like
let's do it and then we poured it we p P
up we we poured up a cup of lean Texas
man yeah literally Houston
hey um but yeah we we poured up
and so we poured up having a blast yeah
and we're like drinking like I was
chugging it you're supposed to sip it
and I was like chugging it and like I'm
like so [__] tired and I was like
damn like this [__] is lit like this is
fire like I'm like so sleepy like I'm
like catching a
nod so tired he sold me badill and I had
spider dreams that night cuz I took too
much badill bro like I was literally
like seeing figures and spiders and I
found out like 5 years later he was like
bro I sold you badill and I was like
honestly respect like oh my God respect
I didn't know badril came in a liquid
form yeah they sell it like coughing
like cough syrup oh man spider dreams
really scary do not recommend them the
fact that he just casually told you that
is crazy yeah I mean we like stayed
close like he was like a drug dealer but
my town was so small when I was growing
up that like everybody knew each other
so he was just like the homie and like
he did he feel badly about it no we
laughed about it like it was funny um
but I mean it's it's like genuinely
funny like I was just this like random
white kid that wanted to buy lean
because my favorite rappers wrapped
about it like I got what I deserved like
you would be so useful in the case
against two Live Crew they'd be like
look at what they're
doing yeah Justin Bieber does lean
Justin Bieber Justin Bieber does he no I
don't
know I thought I thought everyone
thought him and Selena were on um they
were meth out meth yeah yeah they were
meth yeah I still want to know what the
[__] Justin was doing in that
neighborhood yeah dude the that's my
favorite [__] video like him just
getting out and dancing and doing
push-ups like so awesome oh there's that
one I'm talking about the one where the
out of the back of that Oh I thought you
met when you went to like South there
that one yeah there's that one no I'm
talking about the other one where the
it's like the like the 's like it's
Justin Bieber yeah yeah he's like
following around the camera and he's
like MS13 runs this [__] yeah yeah he's
like his eyes are all bugged out dude
pull that up yeah and Selena's like also
kind of like tweaked a little bit like
[__] awes people are saying they were
buying they were buying [__] and I want
to believe it just based on that video I
know literally same yeah they were so
free yeah let them live let them do
their let them pick up when they need to
pick up for real they're itching
bro what is he
doing all right hey I got Justin Bieber
here at the SW though in my hood homie M
gang nice see you bro good
one then he like I just St Bieber I just
see
Bieber to Bieber yo he that's crazy
that shit's
crazy he's fire that [__] was Justin
Bieber that [__] was Justin Bieber is
also Awesome Justin
Bieber hey you guys want to see Justin
Bieber come over here to um Santa Monica
Western Bieber is just having some fever
yo this guy is so sick that's Justin
Bieber dude imagine being that famous
though that that ms3 that's I was about
to say pause it the fact yeah that's
power that a dude could go Ms gang and
then just go have a good
one that's scary power that's dude I
love fing away and Justin just like yeah
like he was frozen in that moment like
he literally felt like he got caught
there's another angle of like him and
Selena like running out of that door and
around the corner and it's it's really
suspect it's at the end oh it is oh yeah
yeah they
escape that's Justin be for you guys
he's in Hollywood the worst the worst
part of it too yeah I like the videos of
him like uh doing push-ups and stuff
South La So Random car breaks down and
just everyone just like mobs him is like
do [__] push-ups that's hilarious
where where did that happen I had no
idea this
[Music]
one
1 19 he's actually like pushing weight
though look at
[Applause]
that wait so did his car break down his
car broke down that's like the story
behind it dude honestly it's kind of
awesome he's just living life that's
what I'm saying he's free dude they made
him do push-ups and sing
[Music]
he can sing bro he can really
sing what what how long does it take
Triple A to pick Justin [__] Beaver
up I don't I don't think he's waiting
for Triple A dude yeah I think he's wait
I think he's waiting for this [__]
plug to pull up hey he can with that
[__] fun stuff wait that was crazy
dude I'm laughing what what was he doing
there dude having the time of his
goddamn life he was like I'm tired of
the nice guy I need to go and explore
the world yeah literally and I need to
be a part of like true like love and
understanding and he got it okay it's
like crazy he looks like he's tweaked up
he look I mean I he did not crack a
smile once like he literally is like so
in his head about like his state of
being yeah you know like The Confident
tweaker that's the vibe he's giving off
like the like the person like singing in
the middle of the street on like
Hollywood Boulevard yeah dude so far oh
what the hell honestly this is so
sick smoked the damn he went back to
doing push-ups yeah he's he's on some
[__] right now he's he's tweaking right
now dude holy
F what if he's just for the kids yeah he
could be like what if he just got high
as hell he's like I must atone for my um
when I sang that slur that one time yeah
for real I must make right I must make
right I must be
shamed